you've
lived a very interesting life where you
thought about big ideas and you stuck
with them
can you give advice to young people
today somebody in high school somebody
undergrad
about
career about life
i'd say you can make a difference
but in order to make a difference you're
gonna have to have the courage
to
follow through with ideas which
other people might not
immediately understand or
support you have to
realize that if you make
some
some plan that's going to take an
extended period of time to carry out
don't be afraid of that that's true of
physical training of your body that's
true of
um
learning
some profession that's also true of
innovation that some innovations are not
great ideas you can write down on a
napkin
and become an instant success if you
turn out to be right some of them are
paths you have to follow but
remember that you're mortal remember
that you have a limited number of
decade-sized debts to make
with your life
and you should make each one of them
count and that's true in personal
relationships that's true in career
choice that's true in making discoveries
and so on and if you follow the path of
least resistance you'll find that
you're optimizing for
short periods of time
and before you know it you turn around
and long periods of time have gone by
without you ever really making a
difference in the world
you